so happy adjourn here yeah after my
parents died and I didn't really think I
was gonna be able to come back to
Tijuana but you always made me feel like
family you are my family
[Music]
America's handle I just want a family
friend I need you to do a favor for me
first
you mess around and I'll kill you both
to park the car real close to the car
is is you you have to believe me they
made me do it the building that you blew
up the DEA safe house you know how long
you go away for unless you help us get
Moreno Esparza
see the
forget your friend who's coming to save
you whether or not you survive
it's entirely up to you
you gotta learn how to use one of these
a viola bullet
balleseros everything ever since you
showed up the police in one step
you better do what you need to do Toledo
has a mole in his operation
[Applause]
I'm gonna come back for you I'm not
giving up on my family
lavalla in the end
the bullet settles everything
[Music]
[Music]
- wish I did swish yeah
don't worry they'll behead me or the day
after tomorrow
no way
she's running out of time
[Music]
I have to find out
okay
I'm very honored to be named keyhole
Citizen of the Year I'm just a guy who
keeps strif civilization open when you
drive the same road day after day is
easy to think about the road not taken
I was lucky I picked a good road early
and I stayed on mister cocksman what can
I do for it
it's about your son
died of a heroin overdose we had neurons
Kyle wasn't a druggie sorry but all the
parents say that you're gonna have to
say a few words
Kyle's dead tell me what happened you
got mixed up with some drug dealer
why can't you like certain people put
this with all these nicknames speed up
Viking Eskimo it's a gangster thing did
you have a nickname wingman wait am I
gonna kill him no guys one guy could
disappear too who wants me dead
three of Vikings drug dealers have
disappeared what make sure that you
watch on that and that a crime novel
what are you doing
[Music]
good job
this doesn't happen in kyo it just did
[Music]
Nell's cocksman citizen to the year good
for him
[Music]
once everything was awesome
now everything is okay Lucy I brought
you coffee coffee the bitter liquid that
provides the only semblance of pleasure
left in these dark times oh my gosh Ness
did I interrupt you brooding just now
times have changed
you need to change with them we have to
be tough and battle-ready
Oh
sorry the door is slowly closing
oh the pain it's Jane so cold see that
wasn't so bad nothing got in
[Applause]
it's all my fault hang on your fronds
planet we're going you mind if I save
your life not at all are you dangerous
and Raptor trainer I don't get it we'll
help me rescue my friends you don't want
to go anywhere near that sistar system
it's ruled by an alien point only the
toughest you're gonna get out of there
alive
i'm mcqueen whatever I would not be I'm
getting super evil vibes here I can
change my form to something else if this
makes you uncomfortable hey guys
they'll go back don't worry was much
more palatable
[Music]
did you draw double dots on your face
who are you I'm your worst nightmare Oh
me when I'm late to school and I forgot
my homework and my pants are made of
pudding
no I don't
you know just a nurturing genius these
are a little prodigy miles isn't like
other kids this intelligence is off the
charts I don't have an exact score but
it'll be very high he's special on me
what's wrong was miles is having a very
difficult time making friends I want you
to tell me everything that you were
going to say I don't remember anything
miles his brain is extremely well
developed you may need a specialist you
must be miles miles is dangerous I don't
feel safe with him in the house
oh my god
he's so different now
I feel like I don't know him
[Applause]
[Music]
new wheels a pre-celebration for the big
day huh I make your partner baby ceiling
worldwide sports management newest
partner boys club you don't connect well
with men just stay in your lane I'll
trust women who don't get dudes like I
don't trust a man with no eyebrows are
too many keys I know someone you should
talk to I can help you commit with me
why don't we have some tea this is like
dirt oh that's just jasmine tea if you
don't count the weed and the peony okay
[Applause]
oh hello welcome back miss Davis
thank God this one didn't die on me
starting today no more drinking at work
hey that's too much information that's
anything I feel we here after last night
yeah that's what happens when tequila
meets and desperation okay stop saying
things you shouldn't be saying to your
boss holy crap can you hear my inner
thoughts I can only mean stuff that
cloud you're walking through that's my
farts I thought black people stopped
running to have to get out where would
you complain about men trying to keep
you down do we have any meetings on the
books nothing yet except the private
poker game tonight this is not a curse
Asha tete-a-tete
the lady which is doing at the big boys
table huh - quiet I'm bluffing these
fools I'm missing Real Housewives check
finally has a winning hand why am I
thinking in the third person I smell
toast my happiness true wait
I had toast in my pocket Who I am
tripping right now I told him you'd
lived it is they already sees your food
yes it's a reset when you died right
yeah I might be able to help with that
I died 11 times I was stuck reliving the
same day over and over again into
someone wearing a baby mask ordered me
on the night of my birthday
turns out it was my roommate Laurie I
kicked her crazy ass out a window and
killed her which both to Luke but now
I'm living the better version of my life
[Applause]
okay yeah I folded your pants know how
to ended the loop but I'm back oh my god
everything's different this time it's
coming after all of us
if you don't be set the day and try
again they're dead for good aren't they
so I'm gonna have to die over and over
again to save all of you I mean I guess
you could just reset the day yourself
genius idea
I don't stop the killer more people will
die failure is not an option
focus man my money
let's see what you got
Green crisis mode tree who's gonna
pledge Kappa now that we have a death
curse it's just a movie
you see Natalie lots not a fairytale
girls like us don't get that oh why look
in the mirror doll when though Julia
Roberts
every day is payday swipe my card
don't let me not only saying that
romantic comedies are about all those
maybes allows that the terrible pop
songs I think people would have an
easier time seeing you if you were a
little more open you're in your mercy
sir this isn't an emergency room this is
at Williamson I'm oh boy downtown it
looks like somebody's put a beauty
filter across New York City and I win
one what's your emergency
someone's broken into my apartment and
they've taken everything and replace a
little bit much nicer stuff so your
emergency is that your apartment is too
big and you have every shoe you could
ever want
yeah exactly that's what I yeah you give
up you go crazy I hit my head really
hard and I woke up in this alternate
universe and now I have a gay sidekick
who's setting gay rights back like a
hundred years of love working the legs
and guys look at me in the eyes you're
caught beguiling aren't you are you
feeling what I'm feeling
No
think I'm trapped enough my romantic
comedy
[Music]
okay boots what's the update I have to
get a man to fall in love with me yeah
I'm Josh he's such a beautiful me
[Music]
good morning beautiful last night was
amazing I didn't think we actually did
anything it just cut to the next morning
what just get back here okay last night
was amazing
Natalie I love you told me the story of
the war when the ground shook in the sky
burn
of the ones that survived who awoke to a
different world
or the powerful right but that's not the
way it has to be when I found you
you're very human brain was miraculously
it's the loneliest feeling not to know
who you are in time you'll remember
[Music]
leaders new again it's harsh world down
here you gotta be willing to do what it
takes let that run
[Music]
Mika's she's the last of a kind
she contains technology that have been
lost for 300 years
let me show you something
[Music]
this body I feel a connection to it I
can't explain you know more about me
than you're saying if he does some
things have been in lift forgotten and
I'll find out for myself
she's threatening the natural order of
things I need you to destroy her a
leader they will come for you I'll have
to face them head-on tonight is not a
game
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
I'm with her never mind
whoa it's all so bloody old I think
you're doing you really want to choke
around in trouble oh wait I know you
you're from that weird family aren't you
we're not weird we don't like wrestling
how do you know if you've ever been I've
never had rectal bleeding before but I'm
pretty sure I'm not fan about how about
I shove her head up your ass then we can
find out anyways
[Music]
sorry about that rock four huge fans
thank you so much more advice would you
give us we want to be the next Q what
are your names get - what's your names
are you walk around here interrupting
the rock you like you haven't seen the
Sun in 20 years you like you just
stepped out of Oliver Twist please sir
may I have some more advice you want
some advice here's the rocket biceps
your mouth thanks Dwayne got it
good morning wrestling nerds so this is
where we see whether or not you get to
go on to WWE this is our shortcut Oh No
why do you want a wrestle I'm the
toughest bastard in any room probably
shouldn't swear and when there's ladies
present sorry miss sorry about that
I call your name that means you'll be
coming with me to Florida page thank you
all very much
you have to take my brother no one
deserves this more than Zach I wish you
the best son this is the end of the line
for you do you know what it's like to
one thing in life and then your own
sister takes it away from you it was my
dream to I have no idea who owns this to
be out there you're not just doing this
view you're doing it for the family
[Music]
Paige I myself have come from a
wrestling family too I know exactly what
it means to you don't worry about being
the next me be the first you
what mr. Wayne Johnson how are you prove
it is cookin yeah and I'm Vin Diesel
might I'm sorry there were dragons when
I was a boy where they went only a few
know our story changed the world forever
we did it the world's first dragon
Viking utopia Julia don't be a baby
Mike slay splendid and more oh Santa
honey hey bud wait up
[Music]
he's not the only wine she's a light
fury you oh sorry did he just disappear
[Music]
Wow
it's a hidden dragon worth
toothless go introduce yourself
[Music]
toothless has a girlfriend I've hunted
every Night Fury except yours and him
over I will never give him up then I
will destroy everything you love
we are no longer safe here we all have
to disappear completely off the map we
have to fight for their freedom you
don't nothing without your dragon
show them what you got but
[Music]
save him
if you and me bud always
[Music]
you